[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندما أحتاج من قبل وأخبرتهم
أنني أستاذ
، لقد فوجئوا حقًا
بسبب ضآلة الحديد
ولأنني من الواضح أنني تلك الفتاة في الأخبار
[الموسيقى]
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
اسمي Nora finish Diana ، أنا
أول من قفز في العالم إلى المصارع المحترف ،
بدأ حبي من السباق عندما كان عمري 4
سنوات من العمر ، كان هناك عندما بدأت
ألعب لعبة فيديو الزوجي مع
أخي ، لذا بدأت في المشاهدة منذ ذلك الحين
المصارعة على التلفزيون مثل كل أسبوع ، لذا
لم أكن مثل ربما يمكنني تجربة
المصارعة المحترفة ولكن في البداية لم يكن لدي
ثقة كافية للانضمام إلى مصارعة المحترفين
لأنني كنت محجبة ، ثم عندما أفكر
مرة أخرى أنه أخبر طلب الحجاب ليس هناك
عذر لذلك  أنا لا أتابع ما
أصطاد حوله في
العمل ، ويقولون إنني
لا أستطيع المصارعة لأن المرأة ستمارس
رياضة شديدة ولكن بالنسبة لي لا
أمانعهم حقًا لأن الناس
يقللون من قدرتي ، فهذا يحفزني ويتحداني
للعمل  أفضل
[موسيقى]
في المصارعة الماليزية نحن فقط
لدي دورة ثانية من CEQA عندما بدأت لأول مرة ،
لم تعاملني بشكل مختلف
لأنني كنت فتاة مثل تلك التي كنت أربيك عليها ، لقد
عاملتني تمامًا مثل الرجال الذين
ندربهم مرتين ، وعادة ما يكونون في غضون
حوالي 4 إلى 6 ساعات  وأثناء
التدريب ، أقوم بتمارين القلب لمدة ساعتين ، كنت
غبيًا بما فيه الكفاية وبعد ذلك أربع ساعات من
التواجد في الحياة الواقعية كما تعلمون
، وداعًا جدًا عندما أستريح ، يمكنني
أن أكون مثل شخص آخر مثل
شخص مختلف
[موسيقى  ]
نظرًا لأن معدل الذكاء ، قلت الطاقة من
الحشد وأصبحت
[تصفيق]
أنا أول امرأة في ماليزيا
تجبر الناس على البطولة عندما
أصبحت فيروسية ، تلقيت الكثير من الرسائل التي
تخبرني بالشكر ويقولون إنني
أعطيهم  أكثر ثقة بشأن السيارات أو
استثمار المرأة المفقودة ، خاصة إذا كانت
تبحث عن تضخم الغدة الدرقية ، لدينا فتاة في وظيفة حضن الشجرة
قادمة للتجربة وقالوا
إنك مستوحاة مني وهو أمر مدهش
أن تكون وجهًا للاستقطاب العنصري ،
إنه شيء لم أفكر أبدًا في
أنني "  م ستكون ب  ut
[موسيقى]